what's going on guys
Christopher Nolan's massive epic
interstellar is in theaters now whether
you love it or you hate it you gotta
admit there's a lot of science up in
there today we're bringing in our
resident physicist dr. Clifford V
Johnson to break down the science of
interstellar dr. Clifford V Johnson
welcome back to screen junkies it's a
pleasure to be back oh it's great to
have you back you always class up the
joint you're very kind
so we're here today talking about
interstellar did you like the movie I
did let me ask you this we're gonna get
into specifics but how accurate was it
well that's sort of hard to say because
there's some real science in there that
seems crazy but it's actually true right
of alongside some real science fiction
are blended together nicely so at
accuracy it's just it's it's it's hard
to give us a score because it's
complicated but give it a score I would
give it a 7 let's get into some of the
science how is the portrayal of
wormholes I liked it of course we have
no reason to think wormholes actually
exist oh I was pleased with the way they
were visualized even though we know that
right now they're not necessarily
science fact what is a wormhole a
wormhole is very simply put like a like
a subway tunnel in a way it's a way of
getting from one part of the universe
one part of space and time to another
part of space-time via a shortcut and
you described as a subway is it anything
like a subway sandwich shop I've never
actually eaten the subway sandwich this
is too ridiculous
Raven continuing after I can't believe
everyone's eating a Subway sandwich no I
I don't think I have that's more
ridiculous than any in science the movie
that you've never eat the subway
sandwiches out there right there's a lot
of I'm not saying it's the best but it's
sometimes you're in a hurry and you
gotta have subway yeah dr. Johnson this
calls all of your reasoning um okay
let's continue though how was the
depiction of black holes I also like
that no black holes we know out there
major parts of our what if I called bull
you could do that but that won't stop
them from being out there okay one of
the big questions is how do they really
look if you're close up of the kinds
that they were doing this big black hole
called gargantuan yes and so actually
kept thorne who was one of the primary
scientists working on the movie yes help
them get the visualization of that right
and it felt really great to sit there
and and watch this new visualization
think that's actually some new science
as well did the passage of space and
time in the film make sense to you yes
okay that's one of the things people are
most surprised to hear me say yeah but
the thing is that that's one of the
pieces of science that was well used and
at the core of the film Wow
horror of the drama the fact that time
runs differently for people in different
situations especially in this case when
the gravitational fields are very
different one particularly striking
moment in the film was when they visited
that water planet haha that was so close
to the black hole right and then they
got back to the ship and it was 20 years
later did that seem potentially accurate
yes what yes there's some problems with
it which is the following but I let them
have it
so they had this extreme gravitational
wells it was one hour as however many
years yes seven years yeah right
so that was great the only problem is is
that um to get out of that gravitational
well would have taken them using a ship
of such incredible acceleration to get
off yes they wouldn't have had that
you'd have to blast your engines with
more energy more energy than I think
they had on that ship but they got off
the thing they got off the thing so
maybe they did they just didn't show
that yeah yeah cuz it was already almost
three hours so they need to cut oh yeah
long long movie but the point is is that
yes um the gravitational time dilation
happens it's a real thing it happens
here - all right now your poem Ella no
I'm not okay with the Lodhi how does it
happen here remember what I said is you
need a you need a variation in the
gravity or gravitational well so gravity
here on surface of Earth yes is stronger
than it is further say up in orbit Oh so
astronauts
they're actually aging slightly faster
than we are down here it's not as
extreme as for the gravitational
situation in interstellar so we're
talking micro fractions of a second
difference in time per year so you know
they're not going to notice it but it's
measurable what was the deal with the
giant bookcase uh war do you want to
know exactly what was up with it
where was he what was that a depiction
of so that was the that was the part
where we went into full-on
science-fiction uh gobbledygook using
some ideas that some of us play with in
our research
might we also call it nonsense I would
prefer to call it highly speculative
okay I think the idea was that what he
saw when he went into that place
whatever it was a bookcase was was
guided by his own desires his own hopes
his own psychology so he wanted to get
home somehow and so that meant that
that's what he saw now you might want
something else like a Subway sandwich
when you fall into the black hole so
maybe hunger so maybe you'd end up in a
subway hmm so the idea was that it was
guided by I wouldn't be able to get the
subway I just have to what I push
Tomatoes all the thing you place order
but yeah until they finally give me that
sweet onion chicken teriyaki yeah
um was that the fifth dimension they
were in I think they were implying that
to enable all of that to happen they
were exploiting the existence of extra
dimensions which as we know are
speculative if you had to theorize what
could a fifth dimension be I do theorize
that's actually what I'm paid to do
about precisely those things whoa and so
one of the things you ask yourself is
well you know how how would we see
another dimension how we experience
another dimension maybe some of the
physics that make us exist is just
designed to be only in these dimensions
but there's maybe some other physics we
can connect to we think gravity may be
one of them
which actually can talk to those other
dimensions and so that's kind of what
they were getting at a little bit in the
movie they were saying gravity is one of
those things that we know pervades all
those dimensions if they exist and so
maybe you could communicate across those
and then they through time in as well uh
using gravitational effect right like
you know how he was in that bookcase
everything could I like you know be like
behind the mirror in the dressing room
at Victoria's Secret
if that's a place you want to go that's
probably where you go in that scenario
so you go to Victoria's Secret or subway
he goes to rescue his daughter in the
rest of humanity we all have different
priorities in the film McConaughey said
that he was in a tesseract let me ask
you something how do i phrase this what
the f is a tesseract
it's simply uh it's simply a higher
dimensional cube essentially so you know
on paper you have a square yeah right
oh yeah sure right yeah in three
dimensions you have a cube mm-hmm so
just keep going Adam in hand oh well
okay if you kept going my brain can't do
that where knows we don't have higher
dimensional brains that we're using and
we go into that field no we just have
the regular brains but we we've learned
that you can visualize geometry by
slicing so a tesseract is a higher
dimensional cube and you can sort of see
visualizations of it by slicing it so
you see these sort of square cube like
shapes gotcha
your brain is a higher dimension than
mine okay Matt Damon he improperly docks
his ship and then he blows himself into
space as a scientist how much of a dope
would you have to be to do that well if
you've been perhaps trapped on the
planet on your own for a very long time
with no hope of ever seeing another
human being maybe something snaps in
there and doesn't get repaired what a
dope yeah was there anything in the
movie where you were like oh come on
Nolan I was most puzzled by why at the
very end
for example our hero had to steal the
ship to go and find Anne Hathaway oh
yeah maybe there's a longer version of
the film where we learned that there's
some reason why there are no longer
spending resources on that were you
going on record saying that you want to
see an even longer version of this movie
I'm curious to know if some of the plot
gaps were improved by another 10 minutes
so to recap Matthew McConaughey using
Morse code to communicate on the face of
a watch from another dimension and
Jessica Chastain realizing what was
happening that gets the seal of approval
why not I wouldn't have used most code
dr. Clifford V Johnson thank you for
being here and dropping some knowledge
real pleasure yet again dr. Clifford V
Johnson comes in and blows my mind what
would you like to see him talk about and
break down next is there a movie is
there a TV show leave us a comment in
the comment section below and the best
answer we'll send you a screen junkies
t-shirt I want to thank you for watching
I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on Twitter bye
bye
Batman begins at number six against the
number three Dark Knight Rises so Batman
Begins I didn't like as much as everyone
else really and Dark Knight Rises was a
huge pieces is there one that you would
fit